everyone i'm liz artegara from the gsb
alumni committee in singapore
and i'm really pleased to introduce our
guest speaker today
near ayala who is now also based in
singapore
since march last year near is an alumni
of gsb
08 and he taught as a lecturer in
marketing at
the gsb and at the plattner institute of
design
at stanford near writes about the
intersection between
topics on the intersection between
psychology technology
and business he's the author of two
best-selling books which i highly
recommend
hooked how to build habit-forming
products and
indistractible how to control your
attention and choose your life
and in distracted he's here today to
talk about some lessons from his latest
book indestructible
which is really timely i was telling him
that people need this more than ever
after what you know the lifestyle we've
had to adjust to given the pandemic
and being on 24 7 with technology
his book was recognized as one of the
best business books of 2019
and um you know i think you'll really
enjoy some of the lessons
near we'll speak for about 45 minutes
and then we'll take questions afterwards
so hold your questions we'll open up the
chat and um i'll be able to pick them up
from there
so thank you thank you for joining us
today and over to you now
thank you so much liz it's great to be
here with everyone i just wanted to
start with where my
story began which is with my first book
and this is what i
taught uh at stanford uh at the uh at
the
platter institute of design and before
that at the gsb uh some of you might
remember baba shiv
if you took a class with him bob and i
took this class or
taught this class together uh and this
book was all about
how companies can use the psychology
behind what makes
uh some of the stickiest products in the
world when we think about the kind of
products that get us hooked like
facebook twitter instagram whatsapp
slack snapchat
what i wanted to understand and to
democratize
were these tactics that these companies
use not for their benefit right these
companies have known how to do this for
decades i wanted to kind of steal their
secrets so that the rest of us
can build products and services to get
people hooked for good
and that's exactly what's happened since
my first book was published
companies in the education space like
kahoot use the hook model
to get kids hooked onto online education
companies like fitbot get people hooked
to exercise
the new york times uses the hook model
to get people engaged
with the news so there are lots of ways
that we can use
habit forming technologies and habit
forming products to help people build
good habits in their lives but if hooked
was about how to help people build
good habits of course i wanted to
explore the other side
i wanted to explore what about these bad
habits what happens when products are
designed to be
so good so engaging that sometimes they
become
distractions and so the moment of
reckoning for me in my life
came when shortly after i published
hooked
i found uh that i had to reassess my own
relationship with distraction
when one afternoon i was with my
daughter and we had
this beautiful afternoon planned and i
remember we had this activity book of
different things that daddies and
daughters could do
together and one of the activities in
the book
was to ask each other this question if
you could have
any superpower what superpower would you
want
and i remember the question verbatim but
i can't tell you what my daughter said
because in that moment for whatever
reason
i decided it was a good time to start
checking my phone
and by the time i looked up from my
device i realized
that my daughter was gone that she left
the room to go play with some toy
outside
and i had blown this perfect
daddy-daughter moment
and if i'm really honest with you folks
it didn't just happen once
and it didn't just happen with my
daughter it would happen when i
got to work and i would say oh i'm
definitely going to work on that big
project and yet found
20 30 45 minutes later i was doing
everything but the thing i said i was
gonna do that morning it would happen
when i would say to myself oh i'm
definitely gonna exercise and eat right
and yet i wouldn't
and i wanted to understand why was this
happening
right the problem that we have today is
not that we don't know
what to do we're all highly educated
people here we all basically know what
to do who doesn't know
that basically the way to you know lose
weight and
live a healthy lifestyle is to eat right
and exercise
we know that and yet why don't we do it
we all know that if we want better
relationships with the people we love in
our lives we have to be
fully present with them we know that we
all know that if we want to excel at our
jobs we have to do the work especially
the hard stuff that other people don't
want to do
the question is not that we don't know
what to do heck if you don't know
how to do something google it all the
information is right there on your at
your fingertips
the question is not why don't we do what
we know we should do the question is
why do we get distracted why do we keep
getting
in our own way so if you ask me today
what superpower i would most want i
would want the power
to be indistractible becoming
indistractible
is the skill of the century because
there is no area of your life
that is not affected by your ability to
sustain your attention this is truly
how we choose our life by deciding
whether it's our mental health our
physical health our relationships our
jobs
require us to be able to pay attention
and to be able to sustain that attention
and throughout whatever task we decide
we want to accomplish so uh
the way we should start thinking about
how do we become indistractible how do
we control our attention and choose our
life
i think is to give us a little bit of
historical perspective
which is to say that distraction is not
a new problem
that in fact even though people today
think that oh it's facebook it's twitter
it's my iphone it's these technologies
that cause distraction
nothing could be further from the truth
that in fact 2500 years ago the greek
philosopher plato
talked about accracia the tendency that
we all have to do things against our
better judgment
so this is not a new problem this is an
age-old part of the human condition
the fact that we all do things against
our better judgment we all get
distracted and if plato was complaining
about how
distracted people were 2500 years ago
then that means that the cause the root
cause of this problem
can't just be in our in our cell phones
it has to go much deeper than that
and so to start our journey to become
indistractible we really need to
understand what is this word
distraction what does that word even
mean i thought i understood it's one of
these terms that everybody thinks they
understand
but when you really press them on it
turns out i didn't have a very good
understanding of what that word even
meant
and the best way to make sure that we
understand what something is
is to understand what it is not so if i
asked you what's the
opposite of distraction what's the
opposite of distraction
most people will tell you that the
opposite of distraction of course is
focus right isn't that the opposite of
distraction focus
well not exactly you see the opposite of
distraction if you look at the origin of
the word
is not focus the opposite of distraction
is traction that in fact both words come
from the same
latin root trajare which means to pull
and you'll notice that both words end in
the same six letters a-c-t-i-n that
spells action
so traction by definition is any action
that pulls you towards what you said you
were going to do things that you do with
intent things that move you towards your
values and help you become the kind of
person you want to become
the opposite of traction is distraction
distraction is any action that pulls us
further away from what we
plan to do things that we are not doing
with intent things that pull us away
from our values
and further away from becoming the
people we want to become
so you say okay whatever this is just
semantics what's the big deal this is a
really important point because i would
argue
that any action can be traction
or distraction let me give an example
before
i wrote this book before i wrote
indestructible
my daily routine looked like this i
would get to work
i would look at my to-do list and i
would say to myself ah okay
i've got this big task i need to
accomplish this thing i've been
procrastinating on
that's what i'm gonna do i'm gonna get
started on that right away let me do
that because that's the most important
thing i gotta do it here i go i'm gonna
get started
but first let me check email first right
let me just scroll that slack channel
real quick to catch up on things because
that's a work related task right i gotta
do that
anyway at some point today so that's a a
working related type of thing that you
know it's okay if i
just do that first how many people does
that happen to right that happens to us
all the time and we justify these
distractions by thinking that they're
work related and i call this pseudo work
because this is the most dangerous form
of distraction
the distraction that tricks us
into prioritizing the urgent at the
expense of the important
so anything can become a distraction if
that is not
what you plan to do just because it's a
work related task doesn't mean it's not
a distraction in fact it's more so a
distraction because you don't even
realize
you've gotten distracted now just as
anything can become a distraction
anything can be traction so i am not one
of these chicken little tech critics
that we hear about all the time
that tell us that technology is
hijacking our brain
that it's addicting everyone there's
nothing you can do about it and that
there's some kind of moral hierarchy
that places some pastimes above others
nonsense garbage anything you want to do
with your time whether it's
play a video game scroll social media
watch the video on youtube
is fine i'm not going to tell you not to
do any of that stuff
anything you want to do with your time
is fine
as long as you do it according to your
values
and on your schedule the time you plan
to waste
is not wasted time anything can be
an act of traction as long as it is done
with intent okay so now we have traction
we have distraction the next question is
well what prompts us to traction and
distraction here we have what we call
two different types of triggers the
first kind of trigger is called an
external trigger an external trigger
you'll be very familiar with
these are the pings the dings the rings
anything in our outside
environment that can lead us towards
traction or distraction these are kind
of the usual suspects what people
tend to blame when they get distracted
they say oh my phone buzzed my
kids interrupted me my colleague needed
something that tends to be the source of
what most people blame on distraction
however it turns out that that is not
the leading cause of distraction
the leading cause of distraction there
was a study that was actually published
just a few months ago that showed this
uh how profound this in this is that
90 of the time nine zero percent of the
time that you
check your cell phone you are not
checking it because of an external
trigger
you are checking it because of an
internal
trigger what is an internal trigger an
internal trigger is an
uncomfortable emotional state that we
seek to escape from loneliness fatigue
uncertainty fearfulness anxiety
stress these uncomfortable sensations
that we
seek to escape from this is the leading
cause of distraction these uncomfortable
sensations that we must escape
from and so as we begin our journey to
become indistractible
we have to understand the discomfort we
are trying to escape because let me tell
you
it doesn't matter what the distraction
is whether it's too much news
too much booze too much football too
much facebook whatever it might be
if we don't understand that distraction
begins from within we will
always look for something to take our
minds
off of these uncomfortable emotional
states so the first big lesson i want
you to write down and remember
is that time management requires
pain management let me say that again
time management requires pain
management because when it comes to
these internal triggers
we really only have two choices here
there's only two things we can do with
those uncomfortable sensations
we can either fix the source of the
problem
right figure out what's causing us that
discomfort and do something about it
or we can learn tactics to cope with it
so let me give you just a few tactics i
wanted to give you some very practical
techniques that you can take without
reading the entire book but just some
some quick hits i can give you
immediately
that you can use starting today to help
you start
mastering these over these internal
triggers
starting with noting the sensation
psychologists tell us that by
simply becoming aware of that sensation
and writing it down
stress anxiety boredom fearfulness
whatever it might be
if you can note the preceding emotion
that comes before the distraction
that's a huge step forward so i was
feeling lonely
so i checked facebook i was uncertain so
i googled
i was bored so i checked the news
stock prices sports scores whatever it
might be if you
can identify and write down that
preceding emotion that's the very first
important step the next thing we want to
do is to get curious
not contemptuous you see many people
when they get distracted
they beat themselves up we call these
people the
shamers the shamers they
take it on the inside they say oh there
must be something wrong with me
uh maybe i have a short attention span i
have an addictive personality i need
some kind of diagnosis to tell me what's
wrong with me
the shamers actually make the problem
worse because shame is a very
uncomfortable internal trigger and we
know what happens the worse we feel
the more likely we are to seek escape
with
more distraction so we don't want to be
shamers
the other group of people are what we
call the blamers the blamers say
oh you see it's social media it's my
cell phone
it's email it's the world these days
right how often do we hear people say
things like this these are the blamers
but of course blaming things outside
yourself doesn't fix the actual problem
we're not going to go back into some
time machine to a
magical time before distraction
distraction has always been here and it
always will be here
so blaming things outside yourself is
futile shaming yourself is futile so if
we're not going to be blamers we're not
going to be shamers
we want to be claimers what does a
claimer do
a claimer claims how they respond hence
the term responsibility
to these uncomfortable sensations to
these urges
it's almost like a sneeze okay you can't
control
the urge to sneeze once you feel the
urge to sneeze
you've already felt that urge the
question is what do you do with that
urge do you let yourself
sneeze all over everyone in the room and
get them sick hopefully not
the responsible thing to do is to take a
handkerchief and cover your face
right and it's the same way with our
emotions we do not control these
urges we do not control the internal
triggers that prompt us to distraction
all we can control is how we will
respond
to that discomfort will we allow the
discomfort
to lead us towards escaping that feeling
with
unhealthy distraction or do we harness
that discomfort
and use it like rocket fuel to help us
propel
towards traction so one of the
techniques that we can use that
psychologist recommends and this comes
from acceptance of commitment therapy
is surfing the urge when psychologists
tell us that
emotions these urges these internal
triggers
are very much like waves right that in
the moment when we
feel these uncomfortable sensations we
think they're gonna last forever but
they never do
they act just like waves they crest and
then they subside
and if we can learn to surf the urge
this is
one of many techniques that we can use
to master these
internal triggers so what does this look
like what we want to do is
utilize what we call the 10 minute rule
the 10 minute rule says that we can give
in to any distraction whatever that
distraction might be
but not right now okay we're not going
to tell ourselves no
we're not going to use strict abstinence
strict absence can
backfire instead we want to do is not
tell ourselves no
we want to tell ourselves not yet and
this is just as effective whether it's
hey i i really need to work on this big
project not check email or
i really want to avoid eating that piece
of chocolate cake because i'm trying to
uh to stick to my diet or i really want
to avoid smoking that cigarette we're
not going to tell ourselves
no we're going to tell ourselves not yet
and what we're going to do is set a
timer
for just 10 minutes and if we still
desire if we still have that craving
hey we can give into that sensation in
10 minutes but for those 10 minutes
here's what i want you to do
i want you to either get back to the
task at hand get back to whatever it is
you said you were going to do that act
of traction
or get curious about that sensation just
sit for a moment
and experience what it is that's going
on inside your body right now
okay with curiosity now with contempt
don't be a blamer don't be a shamer
but instead just reflect upon that
destination okay what am i experiencing
right now
this is a method to help us surf that
urge and what you will find is by the
time those 10 minutes are
up 9 times out of 10 you won't feel that
urge anymore it will have crested and
subsided
just like a wave and your job is to surf
that urge
like a surfer on a surfboard so those
are just a few
techniques there's a lot more in the
book that we don't have time for today
but just want to give you a few very
practical tips
the next step to becoming indistractible
is to
make time for traction right we talked
about the difference between traction
and distraction another thing i want
everyone to remember
is that we cannot call something a
distraction
unless we know what it distracted us
from let me say that again you cannot
call something in distraction
unless you know what it distracted you
from so
you know over the years i've worked with
hundreds of people and many times now
he'll hear people telling me
you know i can't seem to get anything
done i've got a to-do list a mile long
and for some reason
i keep getting distracted that uh you
know my kids want this and my boss wants
this and oh my goodness did you see what
happened in the news today
i i just keep getting distracted and
then i'll ask them
well what did you get distracted from
exactly what did you plan to do with
your time
and nine times out of the out of ten the
answer is i'm not really sure
right but look at my to-do list i didn't
finish all these things i plan to do
but that's not the question the question
is what did you get distracted
from how did you plan your day and for
the vast majority of people
they don't keep a schedule even if you
do keep a schedule most people
don't keep the schedule properly because
in this day and age
if you don't schedule your time down
to the minute someone's gonna schedule
it for you
okay this is called time boxing and this
is a technique that has been studied
for decades this is one of the most
effective things you can do
to become indistractible is to use this
technique of
time boxing to plan out how you want to
spend your time in fact
this is the only way to know the
difference between
traction and distraction everything you
plan to do with intent is traction
everything else is distraction now i'm
not telling you to be
an automaton and only do work all day no
i want you to plan time to be with your
kids
to play video games to watch movies on
netflix whatever it is you want to do
that you find
fun great do it but do it on
your schedule not somebody else's
certainly not the tech company's
schedule
what we want to do is to plan the time
not the output
you see most people myself included we
utilize
this terrible technique of running our
life
with a to-do list i'm gonna kill this
sacred cow right now
because running your life with a to-do
list is one of
the worst things you can do for your
productivity now
i'm not saying it's not a good idea to
write down the things you need to get
done that's fine right get them out of
your brain and get them on paper
get them somewhere outside of your head
what i'm against
is waking up in the morning first thing
you look at when you say what am i
supposed to be doing
is if you look at your to-do list before
you look at your calendar
you've already lost why because a to-do
list gives us
no constraints and what we do is add
more and more and more to our to-do list
and we end up in this terrible cycle of
not getting those things
done and so what happens at the end of
the day
when we look at this all this unfinished
work that we didn't get done
and we say to ourselves wait i said i
was going to do this stuff and i didn't
what does that say about me what does
that say about my personal integrity
right if i keep lying to myself day
after day week after week month after
month year after year
i begin to internalize this new
self-image
of someone who doesn't follow through
and now i start believing wait a minute
maybe i'm not good with time management
maybe i'm not the kind of person who can
focus
and now we've lost the war so as opposed
to planning the output as opposed to
measuring yourself
based on how many boxes you checked off
try
measuring yourself instead by the input
not the output what is the input for
knowledge workers what do we what's the
input to do the kind of work we have to
do
it's only two things our time and
attention
our time and attention so what i want
you to do is to start measuring yourself
based on a new metric not how many boxes
you checked off
but by this new metric of did i do what
i said i was going to do
for as long as i said i would that's it
did i do what i said i was going to do
for as long as i said i would so if i
said i'm going to you know work on that
proposal
for 30 minutes or i'm going to make an
hour of sales calls or i'm going to
check email for an hour and a half
whatever it is
did i do that and only that for as long
as i said i would and here's the kicker
the people who use this method the
people who use this time boxing
technique
have been shown to actually finish more
they
get more done than the people who use
the time boxing technique
so plan the time the input not the
output
the next thing we need to do is to spend
less time communicating
and more time concentrating you see
there are two
types of work we have what we call
reactive work
and reflective work reactive work is how
most people spend their time right they
react to emails react to slack
notifications react to meetings react to
phone calls
all day long reacting and they put no
time in their day
for reflective work reflective work is
the kind of work
that is required for planning for
thinking ahead
forth for for deciding what really
matters for prioritizing
all that kind of work requires
reflective work and it must be done
without distraction so if you want a
huge leg up if you want a competitive
advantage over everyone in your industry
do something that nobody else is doing
make time to think now i don't care if
it's 30 minutes 45 minutes an hour in
your day
have that time carved out and keep it
sacred protect it
make sure you have time in your calendar
to do that reflective work all of us
require at least some
time to do that reflective work without
distraction
now part of the reason that all this
communicating all this
email and slack notifications is so
corrosive
to our productivity and can be such a
source of distraction is because it
comes
coupled with these external triggers
these pings dings and rings
that can so frequently lead us off track
well there's actually a way that we can
hack back these external triggers and
and to get you thinking about how we can
hack back how we can fight against these
external triggers
i want to ask you if you can think for
yourself here for a minute
if i were to ask you what is the third
leading cause of
death in the united states now this
statistic is before corona so don't
think about 2020 think about 2019 and
before
if i were to ask you what was the third
leading cause of death in the united
states of america
i'll give you the first two okay number
one was heart disease
number two is cancer number three
believe it or not
if it was a disease would have been
prescription
mistakes prescription mistakes people
inside medical facilities inside
hospitals
receiving the wrong medication or the
wrong dosage of medication
from health care providers can you
believe it's a huge huge problem
that is until a group of nurses at ucsf
decided to tackle this problem and they
wanted to figure out what was going on
here
why were so many people getting the
wrong dosage of medication or the wrong
medication completely with such
disastrous consequences
and they found that lo and behold the
reason the cause of this problem
was distraction that what was happening
that
on average when nurses were dosing out
medication they were interrupted
10 times on average by their colleagues
and every time they were distracted they
made mistakes
and these mistakes had dire consequences
for their patients
now why am i telling you this story i'm
guessing very few of you are nurses in
healthcare
i'm telling you this story because of
course we have the same
effect on our work when we are
constantly distracted when we
are taken off track by these external
triggers whether it's from colleagues
kids emails slack notifications whatever
the case might be
we also make mistakes and we don't even
realize we're making these mistakes just
like these nurses
who were dosing out the wrong medication
they didn't realize they were making
these mistakes
until it was too late well the good news
is
that these nurses when they conducted
this study
found an ingenious solution that reduced
prescription mistakes
by 88 did you hear that they reduced
this problem by almost
88 and the solution was not some fancy
new technology it wasn't some
expensive retraining program the
solution believe it or not
was cheap plastic vests
plastic vests that these nurses wore
that told their
colleagues drug round in progress do not
disturb how simple was that another
thing they did
they marked specific areas that when
a nurse was working in this area this
was a no interruption
zone okay almost eliminated this problem
completely
so why am i telling you this story well
i'm telling you the story because
we can apply this in our own lives if
we're knowledge workers whether we're
working in an office working at home
we can do something very similar we can
also hack back external triggers
so every copy of my book indistractible
comes with this
screen sign that you can tear out of the
book it's made of card stock
you fold it into thirds and you put it
on your computer monitor
for those of you who are back in the
office you can use this to tell your
colleagues hey you know what
for this hour for this 30 minutes
whatever the case might be
this is my reflective work time i can't
be interrupted unless it's really
important so what you're doing is
interrupting the interruption but you
say yeah but i'm working from home right
now right don't you know there's a
pandemic going on of course i do
well here's the thing we can utilize
this same technique when it comes to
distractions that may
come from our kids from our spouse from
our uh
roommates they can also be a source of
distraction how do we do that
well this is a picture of my wife
wearing what we call in our household
the concentration crown and the
concentration crown is a way for us to
signal
to our daughter we we implemented this
when she was just six years old
and we told her look when mommy is
wearing a concentration crown
that means that she cannot be
interrupted okay
and it works like a charm i also have a
concentration crown it doesn't look like
this
but anybody can do this with just
whatever silly hat you can find around
the house if you have
young kids at home you let them know hey
when when i'm wearing this hat
that means i can't be interrupted
because frankly they don't know if
you're on your laptop
they don't know if that's the kind of
work that uh requires focus or not
the concentration crown or an idea like
it interrupts the interruption
another thing we can do as we're working
from home is to have
digital uh versions of this with our
colleagues so for example
you can use this free free service
called is busy dot app you can see the
url at the bottom which
tells your colleague the equivalent of
that screen
sign virtually so before a colleague
interrupts you with a phone call they
can check real quick to see
hey are you available for interruption
is this time when you're
doing reactive work or reflective work
based on this
quick url they can see what you're up to
another thing we can do is to use
technology
to help us hack back the interruptions
that come
from technology so all of us today have
phones
that come built in with this amazing
function called do not disturb while
driving
so when you plan that time in your day
when you're going to work without an
interruption you know many people have
this fear yeah but what if there's an
emergency
what if somebody needs me right no
problem you
turn on do not disturb while driving
which comes on everybody's android and
iphone
and if someone calls or texts you
during that time when this feature is
engaged they will get
an automatic response that says i'm
sorry i can't talk right now
but if this is urgent text me with the
word
urgent and if they text back the word
urgent
then the message will come through i've
been using this feature for years now
let me tell you there i haven't been
interrupted even once because they know
that okay i'll get to it in 30 minutes
or an hour when
when when i have time and look if it's
really so super urgent they can always
text you the word and the call
will come through and the text message
will come through another thing we can
do is to hack back the external triggers
that
clud clutter our digital space so how
many of us
have desktops that look like this
studies find that digital clutter
is a huge drag on our productivity well
we don't have to live this way
we can take all those files all those
external triggers that don't serve us
put them in a big folder call that
folder everything and have a nice
pristine desktop so that we can actually
focus on our work without these constant
external triggers
the same goes for our phones you know
how many of us have constant
notifications pings and dings
well look there's nothing that mark
zuckerberg and jack dorsey can do if we
change
those notification settings two-thirds
of people with a smartphone
two-thirds of people's smartphone never
change their notification settings
can we honestly say the technology is
addicting us that it's hijacking our
brains
when we haven't taken even a few minutes
to change those notification settings to
make sure
that they are serving us as opposed to
us
serving them you know these technologies
are wonderful
as long as they are serving us so by
asking ourselves this fundamental
question
with all the various external triggers
in our life of is this trigger me
or am i serving it this is how we can
make sure that we can
hack back these uh these external
triggers by adjusting the notification
settings
and then finally making sure that when
we are together
right if we are going to meet whether
it's in a business context
a family context if we are going to be
together
in the physical world we need to be
present both in body and mind which
means that when we're going to get
together
let's leave those distracting devices
outside of those meetings until they're
over
now the last thing we can do is to
prevent distraction
with pacts this fourth and final step
now this
is the firewall against distraction this
is the last
step that we take after we've done the
other three steps first
preventing distraction with pax utilizes
a 2500 year old technique that is first
described in the story of the odyssey
now in the story of the odyssey written
by homer 2500 years ago
homer tells us about ulysses this hero
that has to sail his ship past the
island of the sirens now the sirens
are these mythical creatures that sing
this magical song
that anyone that hears the siren song is
compelled to crash their ship
on the shore of the silence sirens
island and dies
now ulysses knows this is going to
happen he knows about this threat he
knows that he might get distracted by
the siren song
and he's smart enough to take action
today
to prevent getting distracted tomorrow
what does he do
he tells his crew to put beeswax
in their ears so they can't hear the
sirens song
and then he instructs them to bind him
to the mast
of the ship and he tells them no matter
what i do no matter what i say
do not let me go and you know what
his plan works ulysses is able to sail
his ship
past the shore of the sirens island and
return his crew
and his ship safely home now why do i
tell you this story
because of course there's lots of
distracting stuff out there
you are ulysses and of course that could
be you there on the sirens island
dead so we want to make sure that we
take steps
to prevent us from getting distracted as
the last line of defense
by entering what today we call a ulysses
pact
how do we make a ulysses pact well it
turns out we can make
pacts by using the very technology that
can oftentimes be the source of
distraction
these are two tools i use almost every
single day on the right you see self
control which is an app
for for your desktop that when you
engage
will prevent you from accessing
any app or website that you determine in
advance
on my phone i use this great app called
forest forest is wonderful every time i
need to do writing time
i need to do my reflective work time uh
i and i and i think i
might be tempted towards distraction i
open up this
neat little app i dial in how much time
i want to do my reflective work for
i hit this button that says plant and as
soon as i hit plant
this cute little virtual tree is planted
on my screen
now if i pick up my phone and i do
anything with it
that cute little virtual tree dies
it gets chopped down so that's enough of
an incentive i don't want to be a
virtual tree murderer
so it's enough of an incentive to remind
me oh wait a minute that's not what i
wanted to do right now i want to stay
focused on this other task right now i
want to do my reflective work
don't pick up my phone right now it's a
bit of a promise i made to myself a pack
that i
entered to keep me on track is the last
line of defense
another thing that you can do is to get
a focused friend right so if you have a
colleague at work that you can sit down
with maybe you can go to a coffee shop
together or
you know find time uh specifically to
keep each other accountable
and of course i know many of us are
working from home we can't work together
no problem technology to the rescue
there's a great website called
focusmate.com that i use so often i love
so much
actually invested in the company here's
how it works when you want to do your
reflective work you book that time in
advance let's say you say if you're
anything like me
you have trouble getting started in the
morning but you really wanted to do that
reflective work time
you booked that time on your calendar
you can see it here on the left hand
side let's say
8 am is the time you want to get up and
really start doing that that reflective
work time
but you need a little you need a a
firewall you need some some
accountability
well you find a focus friend on this a
focus mate on this calendar
and at that time you'll get a video feed
of your focus mate you can see here on
the right hand side this was a medical
school student in the czech republic who
was memorizing human anatomy while i was
preparing this presentation
and we checked in took us you know five
seconds say hello what are you working
on what are you working on
go having that accountability having
that person that you are making a
pact with can be an incredibly effective
way
to make sure you stay on track so we can
reduce distractions with these packs we
can
use tech to block out distractions
but let me give you a word of warning
you must be careful
okay two really important things to
remember here number one
this comes last don't jump into making a
pack there's other packs we didn't
discuss as well but are very important
price packs effort packs and identity
packs
that you can use but don't jump into it
before
first doing the other three steps you
have to first master internal triggers
make time for traction hack back the
external triggers
then as the last line of defense you're
going to make one of these packs
that's one word of warning the other
word of warning is that we know
that for some people this technique
can backfire okay some people this
technique backfires
why those people turns out are people
who have a really tough time getting
back on track
right all of us will fall off track from
time to time we will get distracted from
time and time it's
it happens it's normal the difference
between someone who is distractible
and someone who is indistractible is
that an indestructible person
realizes why they got distracted and
they do
something about it i love this quote by
paulo coelho who said
that a mistake repeated more than once
is a decision
so if we keep getting distracted by the
same things again and again and again
eventually we're deciding to be
distractible
so the difference between someone who is
distractible and someone who is
indistractible is that the
indistractible person
wakes up and realizes there are only
three causes of every distraction
either it's an external trigger an
internal trigger or a planning problem
and they do something about it now a
distractible person gives up
and says oh it's just it doesn't work i
can't make it work for me
and it turns out that one of the
defining traits of those people who
continue to be distractible
are people who don't give themselves
self-compassion
turns out that people who are able to
give themselves self-compassion are much
more likely to achieve
all kinds of goals in life well how do
we cultivate
self-compassion it turns out we
cultivate self-compassion
very simply by talking to ourselves
the way we would talk to a good friend
right so if i were to tell you about
what happened
with my daughter that i'm embarrassed
that i'm ashamed that i got distracted
when i
really meant to be with someone i love
very much would you tell me i'm a
horrible human being
would you tell me i'm a terrible father
not if you were my good friend you
wouldn't say that
but you know what i used to say that to
myself all the time
and it wasn't helpful and it wasn't true
and here's what else isn't true this
notion that there's
nothing we can do to help ourselves
overcome these technology distractions
that somehow technology is
hijacking our brains that we're
powerless to resist that we're addicted
rubbish there is so much we can do we
can master
the internal triggers we can make time
for traction we can hack back the
external triggers and we can prevent
distraction with packs so today i just
covered in the
past few minutes the model the framework
around the first half of the book what
we didn't have time for
is the other context of our lives where
we interact with other people
so even if we become indistractible
ourselves what about
all the environments we operate in right
so the uh the second half of the book
which unfortunately we didn't have time
to go into too much debt but i hope
you'll you'll you'll look into it
further
is about how do we become indistractible
at work how do we build an
indistractible organization
how do we raise indistractible kids and
finally
how do we have indistractible
relationships but the message i want to
leave with you today
is that we can do this i truly believe
that we can get the best out of these
technologies
without letting them get the best of us
we can all become
indistractible thank you so much and
with that i think we have
about 15 minutes for questions would
love to take them so if you want to
start writing them in the chat function
that'd be great
and as i take those questions i have a
quick favor to request from you
if you could be so kind as to take this
quick survey if you go to this url
opinion two dot us notice it's not dot
com it's opinion two dot
us if you type in that url or if you
happen to have your phone handy
you can just point your camera at that
qr code and you'll be taken to
a a google survey where i would love to
hear what you thought of the
presentation i read every single comment
so if you have any
uh uh feedback that would be terrific
i'll take you all 30 seconds to
to uh to do this little survey i have
for you
and when you complete that survey when
you click submit
you will get a link to my slideshare
page
where you can have all the slides you
just saw and i hope you'll you know
share those with uh with your colleagues
with your friends with your family
whoever might find it useful if you find
it useful that'd be great
and if we don't get to your question
today please do visit me
at miranfar.com there's a contact form
there if we don't get to your question
today please feel free to reach out to
me happy to hear from you there
and with that liz i'd be happy to take
some questions
thank you so much nier and i'm sure
everyone in the audience will agree that
you gave some really valuable um advice
all of us needs some um measures
of hacking back you know and making
technology work for us
in you know so that we can focus on our
own values and goals and not
be distracted 24 7. so thank you so much
um i'll start with a question i know
that um
you know it's clear how beneficial these
techniques can be
um for self-management and personal
interests
and i know in your book you go into the
fact that a couple of organizations that
you mentioned
um that have the the image or
the reputation of being 24x7 having a
very full-on work
um culture like bcg and slack um
but but you know they've found a benefit
in having employees that follow
these these principles um can you
briefly comment on that
sure yes so there's a whole section in
the book on how to build an
indestructible workplace uh which is
which essentially acknowledges that look
you know what what if
i'm indestructible okay i'm gonna do
everything near tells me to do i'm gonna
master
internal triggers make time for traction
hack back external triggers and prevent
distraction with packs
but my boss keeps bothering me all day
my boss keeps interrupting me every time
i try and do reflective work my boss
doesn't respect the fact that i need
time to focus well this acknowledges
that
distraction is not just about
our devices it's about company culture
that uh organizations that
have this problem of distraction also
have other problems
right because the real issue about
a surrounding distraction in the
workplace the real cause of the problem
is that we can't
talk about the problem of distraction in
the workplace
that turns out to be the real culprit
so there are a few different facets of a
workplace that is
indistractible right that that a profile
in the book two companies
boston against building group and slack
and we find there are some common
tenants
at these companies and one of the things
that we find
is that employees have a forum
to talk about this problem okay that's
the first
aspect the first trait of companies that
are indestructible people can talk about
this problem with what we call
psychological safety without the fear
that raising this concern
would get them fired because there's
this perception that if i want to talk
about the problem of distraction that
somehow i'm not a team
player that i'm not pulling my weight
and so people don't talk about the
problem at all and it turns
out that if you can't talk about this
problem guess what you probably got all
kinds of other skeletons in the closet
that prevent you from talking about
other problems in your organization
so for example at the boston consulting
group and this is a company that i know
intimately because i used to worry it
was my first job out of
out of college i i worked at the boston
consulting group
and back then circa 2001 it was a
very hard charging 24 7 culture
and they've really reformed that since
they've they've changed many uh aspects
of this because they found that they had
a very high employee turnover
i was one of these employees that just
just couldn't do it because it was
unsustainable to constantly always
be on there was no time where i could
feel like i wasn't connected to the
office
and so they actually worked with a
harvard psychologist uh
uh who helped them establish the
psychological
safety that they needed and the forum to
talk about this problem of distraction
they they implemented what they call
pto predictable time off and here's how
it worked
basically what they did they said what
would it
take to give everyone on a case team
they took one case team of eight people
and they said what would it take here's
the challenge what would it take to give
everyone
one predictable night off where they
could
you know go to dinner with their family
go to the gym uh
watch tv do anything but work just one
night off per week
and when this researcher asked this one
case team at boston consulting group
could we do that
oh she heard every excuse in the book oh
no no we're a distributed workforce
we're in the client services business we
have to be always on impossible
can't happen so here's what she said she
said okay how about this
let's let's let's uh a role play here
that this isn't for us
this is for one of your clients right
your bcg you work with the biggest
companies in the world
what would happen if one of your clients
said hey we want to give every employee
one predictable night off for a week
could we make that happen
okay let's try that and you know what
they quickly figured out ways to give
everyone one predictable night off it
actually wasn't that hard
what they needed was the place to talk
about this problem
without the fear of of retribution
without the fear they'd be judged with
the psychological safety they needed
to talk about the problem so number one
is giving employees psychological safety
to talk about the problem the first
place
number two is giving them a forum to
talk about the problem and at
bcg it was these this this predictable
time off
discussion that that they they now
actually expanded throughout the
workplace
uh i profile in the book slack that does
it a little differently
they don't have these meetings where
they talk about predictable time off
they at slack they actually have
slack channels devoted to what they call
beef tweets
where people have these specific slack
channels where they can voice
concerns right they can voice their beef
with the company and they do something
very interesting they actually use emoji
to show that their these concerns have
been
aired and seen and acted upon so they'll
use management will use the i
emoji to show an employee that yep we
saw that
or a check mark to say yep we're going
to fix that problem again it doesn't
mean that management needs to
always fix every employee concern it
does mean however that employees need to
feel heard and have a place to talk
about those concerns
so number one is is psychological safety
number two is a form to talk about these
problems
number three and perhaps most
importantly
is that management needs to display what
it means to
be indestructible that as we all learned
at the gsb
culture flows downhill so people will
look
to their manager to their boss and see
how online they are how connected they
are what the expectations are
and if they don't walk the walk well you
know they can't talk
the talk either and so one of the things
that i saw at slack that i was amazed
you know this is this hard charging
silicon valley
startup and when i visited them several
years ago they
in the company headquarters and they
still have this at
hq in san francisco when you walk to the
employee canteen right where people are
mingling
you will see in big pink bright letters
neon letters it's written
work hard and go home
okay not what you would expect to see at
a silicon valley
uh startup that's now you know been
acquired by the sales force but this is
what they've had since day one this
this slogan work hard and go home and
they mean it
at 6 p.m the office is empty and if you
check slack after hours on nights and
weekends
you are reprimanded that is not what
they do that is not part of the company
and culture because everybody
from stuart butterfield on down
appreciated this this
this notion that to get our best work
from folks they need downtime they need
time when they can do reflective work or
be with their families or do whatever
else they
intended to do with their time and they
display that to their
workforce by how leadership behaves so
that's the third aspect that
management needs to exemplify what it
means to be indistractible themselves
thank you and those are two great
examples of how this doesn't just work
for the individual it works for the
organization too in the business
i'm seeing some great questions come
across um eduardo is asking what do you
think about the pomodoro technique
sure so the pomodoro technique is one of
many techniques um it's uh it's
essentially time blocking uh by the hour
so saying okay for
the next uh whatever 25 minutes i'm just
going to work on one task
i think it's it's it's a tool it's not
the end all
and and most importantly if you skip the
first step of mastering the internal
triggers
uh the pomodoro technique won't work
because
if you do nothing but set a timer for
yourself
for those of you who aren't aware of the
pomodoro teaching basically you're just
setting a timer
saying i'm going to work for this amount
of time and you don't you try not to do
anything else which is great
but if you haven't first dealt with
those internal triggers
right if you have this burning itch of
oh this task is horrible i really don't
feel like doing it let me just go do
something else for a quick minute
you're gonna fail you're gonna cheat
right uh if you don't hack back the
external triggers if you're constantly
interrupted by pings and dings
you're gonna you're gonna fall off track
if you don't implement these packs
you're gonna fall off track so what i
learned on the five years of research
that i did for
uh indistractable is that it's really
about this concert of using these
four techniques together mastering the
internal triggers making
time for traction hacking back external
triggers and preventing distraction with
pacs
this we got to do all four
that's great thank you stephanie asked
the question how would you address
avoidance
and avoidance behavior and how to
overcome uh
this how do i get i think she means how
did how to
achieve this increased productivity
i i if i if i think i understand
correctly so avoidance meaning this
uncomfortable sensation uh that that
brews up inside of us and then makes us
avoid the task i think that's what she's
asking i'm not exactly sure but
uh that's a great example of an internal
trigger right and the the number one
reason we don't
do what we say we're going to do if
we're really honest with ourselves
is that we don't feel like it right we
know we should exercise
i don't want to i don't feel like i know
i'm supposed to work on that big project
right now but
it can wait till a little bit later it's
feelings at the end of the day
fundamentally procrastination
distraction it's not a character flaw
there's nothing wrong with you it's
simply that we don't have the tools in
our toolkit to deal with discomfort
in a healthy manner so this is where we
have to reimagine the task reimagine the
trigger and reimagine our temperament
so that we have these tools ready so
that when we don't feel like it
okay we know what to do we have ways to
master these internal triggers
great and there's a great section in
your book that
um it was so insightful to me as a
parent
because you gave an example of how this
technique can actually be taught to
children and not to underestimate
their ability to you know to do the same
to
you know identify their priorities and
manage their own schedule and i thought
that was brilliant
so a question came across what would you
say to teens who insist that they can
only do homework with music and social
media
at least going at the same time
yeah so there's a whole section in the
book around uh how to raise
indistractible kids and as
the father of a tween uh you know we
we've uh
that this is very pertinent for us and
it was really important i think if
becoming indistractible is important for
our generation it's even
more important for the next generation
you know that we know where this trend
is going
the world is not becoming less
distracted quite the opposite the world
is becoming a
more distracted place and so i really do
think that there will be a bifurcation
between people
who are indistractible and people who
are distractible people who let their
time and attention be controlled and
manipulated by others
and people who say to themselves nope i
decide how i spend my time
i decide how i control my attention
because that is ultimately how i
choose my life and so it's imperative
that we teach our children
how to be indestructible and so the way
we do it
is with the same four steps right we
understand
their internal triggers there's a larger
discussion there around
why kids are looking for escape it's
actually to me the most
uh maybe the most important part of the
entire book is really understanding
why are kids looking for escape let me
tell you social media video game use
among kids is not the disease it is the
symptom of the disease and there's a
whole discussion we can go into there
around what is really uh
inside going on in kids heads what's a
deeper psychology this is where i refer
to self-determination theory and
and and the the deeper reasons why kids
are looking for
escape through these devices very very
important for us
as parents to really understand the root
causes of distraction because
parents have always been blaming one
thing or another for ruining kids brains
right my generation it was rap music and
before that
uh it was the radio and the television
comic books everything is melting kids
minds and of course
there's always a deeper reason that of
course we as parents don't
really want to think about and talk
about but is imperative for us to
understand
the next step is to make time for
attraction that if
kids uh you know especially now that so
many of us are homeschooling including
in my family
we have to have that schedule and you
know kids starting from you know
school age children need to get into
this practice
of understanding what's in their day
part of the reason that kids have
trouble focusing is that they want to do
the things they enjoy they want to play
video games they want to socialize with
their friends
uh they want to go outside if they're
able to but without having that schedule
without understanding when that time is
coming in their day
they ruminate on it when can i do it
what can i do when can i do it well
you know we know yes it's right there in
the calendar that's when you're gonna
have time to play your video games or do
whatever else
and i promise mommy daddy we will not
interrupt you during that time
very very important to make time for
traction whatever it is they say they're
going to do
hacking back the external triggers this
gets to the question around you know
potential external triggers
look you know if if someone wants music
in the background and they're able to do
what they say they're going to do well
then it's not a distraction that may not
be a problem for them
what i do advise against is having
anything that beeps
boops or buzzes in the bedroom okay
there's no good reason i that i can come
up with why a child
needs a television set you know we talk
about the new latest technologies what
about older technologies
like television like radio anything that
potentially interrupts sleep
doesn't have a place in the bedroom
including of course cell phones and
laptops
so that's about hacking back those
external triggers a good test
of whether a child is ready for a
technology is do they know how to turn
it off right it's a wonderful test when
they come to the dinner table
are they able to turn off their
technologies when they're doing their
homework
are they able to turn on do not disturb
do they understand how to put it away
and if they're
not ready or if they don't know how to
use those uh
those those functions in the or with the
device then they're not ready for the
technology it's kind of like a swimming
pool
right you wouldn't throw a kid into a
swimming pool before they know how to
swim
well we wouldn't give a technology
unless they know how to turn off the
negative aspects of that technology
and then finally making pacts with these
pre-commitment devices
my daughter loves forest it's a very
simple app we talked about earlier the
one with the tree
you know anybody of pretty much any age
can use that type of app to make these
packs
uh and so it's really about the same
four techniques but i will say
the most important thing you can do if
you want to raise indestructible kids
the most important thing you can do
is to set a good example yourself we
cannot tell our kids
you know get off facebook while we're
checking email
right we can tell them stop playing
fortnite while we're
uh engrossed in checking our devices we
have to set that example ourselves and
become indistractible
so for their sake as well as ours that's
great
thank you and um i guarantee to the
audience we've
heard so many um valuable lessons in the
past
hour and i i guarantee that if you read
his
book you'll get even more um you know so
to live better work better
follow these guidelines and read his
book so thank you so much we're at the
top of the hour so that brings us to the
close of the session
and uh thank you all for dialing in from
various parts of the world
thank you everyone take care stay
indistractible